i just step out of the way and show you
just the incredible security operation
there is here we're in a wooded area
just outside wendover in buckinghamshire
there are dozens and dozens of security
private security bailiffs thames valley
police and british transport police here
and still swampy and his mates have
managed to get in there and they've gone
underground now he stayed underground
for 28 days at houston station in
january and february of this year
those charges were dropped against him
last week he got straight out of court
he's got here and at least four
protesters are underground let's bring
in one of their supporters mark here
from hs2 rebellion mark just tell us
what do you hope what do you hope to
achieve here
we do really uh hope to
bring to light what hs2 is doing right
here um the the incredible destruction
they're about to do to the aquifer here
it's going to i'm like the far-reaching
effects of it the grand union canal is
eight miles from here and it is going to
be drying up because of the work that
they're doing here because of the flow
of water through the uh aquifer and
they're going to be blocking it and
i'd like to point out you see all these
people here and you see how active they
are how busy they are
we're all paying for that
the government is adamant that this
project is economically
necessary
and it's going ahead regardless that's
as much
that's just so so much baloney um
and the lies that have come out from
parliament the lies that come out from
the government the lies that come from
these guys
this eviction is going ahead
on perversion of course of the course of
justice from lies that these guys came
out with about us saying that we were
all violent
all the way through the project they are
having to lie to cover up for the
absolute uselessness of the project just
tell me i find it amazing that this area
is literally crawling with security
how have your protesters managed to
breach this security and get themselves
underground into these tunnels you've
dug
we were we were here first
we have we've had these camps here for
up to two years um and yeah we were here
first uh so we knew that this was going
to happen at some point um and the
preparation for that is to get
underground
so your colleagues swampy amongst them
they managed 28 days i think it was in
january and february it was 20 years it
might have been 31. yeah a very long
time at a cost of 3.5 million pounds to
hs2 is that the plan here i mean how
much provisions and stocks and supplies
have they got we could we can hang out
for as long as it takes um whether it's
going to be 31 days i really don't know
um and as for the cost
who cares i might that's a drop tiny
little drop in the ocean in terms of
what we're going to be spending on hs2
we have to stop this project it's going
to cost 237 billion pounds we've got to
stop this now's the time
so the protest continues they've gone
underground and you're here for the long
haul oh yes absolutely i've done four
years i'm going to carry on
mark here from hs2 rebellion thanks for
your time i'll just step out shot sarah
jane and just leave you with the
extraordinary security presence that
there is here dozens and dozens of
bailiffs private security thames valley
police are there in the background in
the yellow florescent jackets and
british transport police here as well
swampy and his mates underground today
is day two of this latest protest